good morning Hank it's Friday October
10th and I'm coming to you today from a
hotel room with two bathrooms no joke
there's bathroom one and here's bathroom
two with its bathtub the size of a
swimming pool
I mean seriously Hank I can hide inside
of it
Oh Oh God the injuries I incur free fall
game so Hank I'm coming to you today
from the iSight camera because I left my
camera charger at home hey just because
I'm on the iSight camera does not mean
that it's not question Friday the day
that I answer real questions from real
nerdfighters
okay Hank let's get to it question one
how long can you go without mentioning
your new book Paper Towns which comes
out in six days and makes a great
present for the holidays I don't know
let's tie me and we'll find out will
Paper Towns be out in Canada at the same
time as it will be in the United States
that doesn't count I didn't bring it up
I just repeated a nerdfighters question
and yes do you think deconstructionism
as a part of literary criticism takes
something away from the author may be
but authors don't own books readers do
do you play any musical instruments
sometimes I play a little upside down
Hotel trash can I I don't have a lot of
aptitude for the upside-down Hotel
trashcan but I do look his bubbles to
nerdfighting puppy neutered yes for the
first several months of his life every
time he peed inside I was like Willy if
you do that one more time I am gonna
chop your balls off and then I did it if
some blips or blobs and some blobs or
believes then our someb lids definitely
believes okay let me rephrase your
question if some nerdfighters make
riddles and if some riddle makers are
minotaurs then are some nerdfighters
definitely minotaurs hmm yes I guess so
are you an octopus hmm one two three
four no wait wait wait wait I could be
an octopus who had had four legs chopped
off okay if I weren't octopus with four
legs chopped off how would we be able to
tell if I jumped against the wall I
would stick
I'm not an octopus
we know that Joe Biden anagrams - I need
job but does Sarah Palin anagram -
anything interesting no joke Sarah Palin
anagrams to Las Piranha how did you get
your hair to be so incredibly awesome is
not a question I received very often in
middle school what's going to happen at
these nerdfighter gatherings songs will
be sung Paper Towns will be read okay
that's it that's as long as I can go
without mentioning Paper Towns I mean my
god it comes out in six days it's the
culmination of two and a half years of
my life huh paper towels paper towels
paper towels paper towels paper town six
days six days six days Paper Towns next
Thursday's Paper Towns but anyway yes
songs will be sung Paper Towns will be
read books will be discussed questions
will be answered stuff will be signed
happy dances will be happily danced how
do you feel about Paper Towns being sold
early in some places I mean I'm not
thrilled about it but there's also
nothing I can do about it it's like this
spot on my shirt how come you never
answer my questions actually by virtue
of answering your question I have
rendered your question unanswerable why
is why only sometimes a vowel because if
it were always a valid there would be no
Yeti and then I would be all alone in
the world oh my god thank you thank you
consonant why will you sign books other
than Paper Towns while you're on tour
yeah absolutely I'll sign anything other
than skin I have a strict no skin
signing policy okay Hank I'll see you on
the internet on Monday and in real life
at the Paper Towns release party on
Thursday